well that didn't take long
the Democrats newest it-girl of income
redistribution Kamala Harris is already
taking big heat from liberal bigwigs
we'll play it for you in a moment now
why on earth would they pick on someone
as brilliant and as accomplished as
Senator Harris well perhaps because she
doesn't understand basic economics you
support the Medicare for all bill I
think initially I believe it will
totally eliminate private insurance so
for people out there who like their
insurance they don't get to keep it
well the listen and the idea is that
everyone gets access to medical care and
you don't have to go through the process
of going through an insurance company
having them give you approval going
through the paperwork all of the delay
that may require who of us does not have
that situation where you got to wait for
approval and the doctor says well I
don't know if your insurance company is
gonna cover this
let's eliminate all of that let's move
on let's move on well anyway the coffee
guy is now saying I'm not so fast that's
not correct that's not American what's
next what what industry are we going to
abolish next that alone would wipe out
millions of jobs of Americans and that
is the kind of extreme policy that is
not a policy that I agree with and if
you take immigration you take health
care what we have is extremes on both
breath both sides not representing the
largeman majority of Americans who don't
have a voice now Schultz is a
businessman and he's certainly no
conservative but he sees the writing on
the wall here he knows that the Democrat
Party is moving so far left that it's
leaving America Democrat darlings like
Kamala Harris are proposing disastrous
socialist solutions to things like
health inequality or wealth inequality
that's those kind of concepts that were
once left to late-night seminars in
college forget the 32 trillion dollar
cost or the 500000 insurance company
jobs that we'd be lost and the Sanders
Harris Warren Plan of Medicare for all
the fastest way by the way to sink
Medicare is to give it to all not just
to the elderly
it will go broke that much faster maybe
even in five years
so even if you tax the rich to death you
still can't pay from Medicare for all
doctors and hospitals would face pay
cuts they're already facing them today
that means more hospitals closing more
doctors retiring are not going into the
profession at all longer waits for even
serious procedures and ultimately this
will lead my friends to ration care
according to age weight and yes other
pre-existing health problems but don't
worry because when you wait in line for
the procedure at least you'll be
comforted to know that the government is
pursuing Kamala's green energy fantasy I
support a green new deal and I will tell
you why climate change is an existential
threat to us and we have got to deal
with the reality of it we have got to
deal with the reality of the fact that
there are people trying to peddle some
idea that we should deny it and they are
peddling science fiction instead of what
we should do which is rely on science
fact so what does the green New Deal
mean for you and your family well it
means the government will reach in and
control monitor and tax even more
aspects of your daily life than it does
now you'll love your car as much as I do
mine's 19 years old I still love it too
bad the Green Party's green new deal
calls for replacing non-essential
individual means of transport with high
quality and modern mass transit this is
kind of a geeky way of instituting a ban
on cars but who decides whether your car
is a non-essential individual means of
transport hmm maybe Kamala and crew will
bring back Obama's green jobs arse why
not to achieve their green transport
utopia quote it will be necessary to
electrify everything else including
transport so if you love your SUV your
sedan heck your hatchback too bad only
electric and if you were deemed worthy
of owning a car at all well remember in
commas gas free world the government gas
bags have all the power an even big gulp
banning bike lane mandating Mike
Bloomberg is balking at Harris's green
folly I'm a little bit tired
listening to things that are
pie-in-the-sky that we never are going
to pass I'm never going to afford I
think it's just disingenuous to promote
those things you've got to do something
that's practical
now that means banning all coal banning
all cars banning all nuclear power
taxing miles driven taxing kilowatts
used taxing water used it would be all
on the table to force Americans to bend
to the fattish trends of the socialist
left now more power for them less power
freedom and prosperity for you it's
always how it works in a fully
centralized economy and this is what is
lighting the Democrat Party and fire
today really
instead of kibbutz in with the NRDC
kamala should have consulted first with
I don't know Kermit
it's not that easy being green well it's
not because as the Kaiser Family
Foundation found recently support for
Medicare for all drops like a rock when
you know how much it's going to cost you
same deal with a green agenda when
people find out how much it cost now get
this 56% of survey respondents initially
said they favored Medicare for all as a
whole plan but when they're faced with
the prospects of paying higher taxes to
fund the system and by the way the
elimination of private health insurance
companies support Falls to only 37
percent and when told that the new plan
could actually threaten the current
Medicare program only 32 percent
remained in favor my friends this is why
it's so critical for the Trump
administration the entire cabinet and
the Republican Party to have a
full-court press of facts out there to
educate vulnerable voters on the green
economy issues on Medicare for all
all of it history shows us that
socialist ideas are always easy to sell
to uninformed indoctrinated and
sometimes desperate voters but it's
impossible to fully fund it never works
it's a false promise of free stuff
forever but as always you eventually run
out of other people's money Kamala
Harris I don't know would do better
pursuing maybe a career as a DJ a song
that has to be played loud because you
have to hear the bass the sun is shining
by bob marley and the wailers
or maybe a backup singer one nation
under a groove getting down just for
about mark of it can I get it on
Wow or I don't know a voice-over artist
right if you buy what she's selling she
may have the last laugh but you're gonna
be crying all the way to the
government-owned bank and that's the
angle